next item the ever present
coronavirus conversation how it's
affected the nfl schedule no positive
test for the patriots or
titans today which is positive news
titan's still set to play the bills
tomorrow night which is good because if
titan's bills gets postponed that's the
first game that goes to an 18th week
whenever that may be
which
who knows at this point because the nfl
is doing their damn just to not even
think about a week 18 hoping that not
thinking about it can will it from
happening shireen let me tell you this
that i heard today i haven't written it
yet at pft
there was a belief
last week in league circles that the
league was going to hammer the titans
with unprecedented punishment one
general manager speculated suspensions
for the balance of the season for coach
mike frable and gm john robinson 10
million dollar fine first round draft
pick gone again that was just a guess
from somebody who runs one of these
franchises now that
there's a vibe that i've picked up on
that the titans may ultimately
not be punished at all
and i'm trying to harmonize that
and it could be
that last week was all about huffing and
puffing to help secure the attention of
the other 31 franchises the ultimate
i'm going to turn this car around
right now if you don't shut up in the
back seat something serene i'm sure both
you and i heard back in the 70s when we
were growing up being loud in the back
seat but i digress but um now there's a
thought
that because it hasn't happened yet
and it stunned me that it hasn't
happened yet
and i thought maybe the nfl is just
making sure they get their ducks in a
row
so they don't get themselves into a
bounty scandal or deflategate type of a
situation where someone like me says
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
you're you're railroading this team
you're not being fair with the facts
you're misrepresenting what happened
you're trying too hard to justify the
punishment
i thought that was the case
someone very influential in league
circles believes that it's just gonna
all die down it's gonna all go away and
it's never gonna be heard from again and
there's so much other stuff going on in
the nfl that it's not going to take long
to run out the clock on the expectation
the titans are going to get punished and
at the end of the day shireen they may
not get punished at all
mike john robinson had a press
conference right before we came on the
air too and
he talked about all the changes they
made within the organization said they
have not heard anything on the penalties
as you said but they've moved 26 lockers
into a bubble to try to spread things
out they've done the air filtration
system they've changed that
he said there were some mask
inconsistencies and they asked what the
inconsistencies were and he said well
not necessarily wearing it over the nose
all the time getting lacks with it
pulling it down things like that so
they're trying to make these changes but
he said they have not heard of of any
punishment that they're going to get
he says he will hold his breath now they
get their test results sometime between
3 30 and 4 30 a.m and they hope that
they're all negative and they've gotten
through this and tomorrow when they wake
up they can play a game and and be on
the right side and they're going to be
missing a couple coaches who aren't
going to be clear they're going to miss
in a lot of players we're already
getting some players coming back off the
coveted list they've had this for so
long but they are going to be missing
some players as they as they go play so
it will be interesting to see if they
are punished by the league i would find
it stunning if nothing is done to them
and i do think you need to send some
sort of a message
that you know you you had some problems
within your organization that you didn't
handle correctly
here's the fundamental dynamic and
here's the real question we've already
gone over but i want to be
clear on this and as concise as possible
how do you prove
that
violations that potentially were
committed by the titans and everyone
else
right all you have to do is watch any
game and you realize that the compliance
with the protocols is far from universal
case in point in the protocols that were
reissued last week a clear requirement
that in buffalo and san francisco masks
must be worn even by players not in the
game well watched the game yesterday
masks weren't being worn for the most
part by the players not in the game so
how do you connect
the reality
that everyone
is failing to comply with the letter of
the protocols at all times with an
outbreak
especially when
the positives are coming in in dribs and
drabs that you can potentially say
there isn't a connection
it's not like everybody sat around the
room together
with their masks off in a meeting room
elbow to elbow and all those guys got it
four days later
and i don't know that that happened with
the titans it could be that just in
nashville there's a lot of people that
have it
and guys are going home and they're
getting it i know the patriots believe
they don't have an outbreak that they
think guys are testing positive through
means outside of the facility so i think
before the nfl picks this fight with the
titans they better be damn sure that
they can win it
because there will be appeal mechanisms
there will be a court of public opinion
run by the media saying wait a minute
nfl we think you're not being fair here
we think you don't have your case
buttoned up and we think what you're
doing to the titans is unwarranted and i
don't think the nfl wants that sideshow
either
that's what's so hard about this virus
is we all know even people outside the
nfl know you don't know where you got it
necessarily all the time you don't know
who you spread it to
you they don't know who they spread it
to and this thing just takes off and you
know as john robinson said we're talking
about a little microorganism here that's
that's gotten in our building somehow
some way and you know whether it's
spreading from player to player or
different people are getting it home and
coming back and tested positive who
knows but yeah they better be 100 sure
if the if and when they penalize the the
titans and if they don't i
hopefully teams have learned their
lesson from what the titans have gone
through that you have to be extra
careful you have to wear your mask
properly within the building at all
times you have to do absolutely
everything you can for risk mitigation
and sometimes that isn't enough but you
have to do everything you can and as
we're seeing again and again and again
it doesn't always happen like that mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports